les 12 européen les 12 pays européens
n'ont pas pris de décision ils ont
reporté à demain cette fameuse décision
sur la fermeture éventuelle des
frontières de l'europe fermeture aux
importations d'animaux vivants et de
produits frais en provenance de l'union
soviétique ou des pays de l'est mais on
s'inquiète dans plusieurs pays européens
par exemple en allemagne à francfort les
autorités de la région de hesse ont
décidé de suspendre les rencontres
sportives dans les stades en plein air
en raison des risques de contamination
des pelous et cela pendant 15 jours
alors en france on ne s'inquiète pas
pour l'instant avec raison semble-t-il
car notre pays jusqu'à présent été
complètement protégés de ses retombées
radioactives
les explications de jacques viol et la
france auraient été épargnés par la
radioactivité de tchernobyl grâce à la
météo lorsque le nuage radioactif est
passé sur la france des 1er et 2 mai
souvenez vous il ne pleuvait pas ce
nuage n'a donc pas été lavé c'est à dire
que les radioéléments n'ont pas été
précipités sur le sol dans les champs et
les rivières al'inverse de nombreux
autres pays européens où il pleuvait
tous les contrôles les relevés de
radioactivité effectuées sur le
territoire est comptabilisé ici au
centre de protection contre les
rayonnements ionisants au vésinet à côté
de paris sont formels et les chiffres le
prouvent pour l'yonne radioactif 1 des
radioéléments et le problème immédiat
dans ce genre de catastrophe
l' oms l'organisation mondiale de la
santé recommande de ne pas dépasser 2000
becquerels unité de mesure par litre de
lait au dos en france selon les
spécialistes ce chiffre n'a jamais
dépassé 200 c'est à dire dix fois moins
et diminue alors que des pays comme la
pologne allemagne de l'ouest la suède
approchait ou dépassait les 2000
becquerels ce qui explique que les
frontières se ferment que les prairies
où paissent les vaches les animaux eux
mêmes soient devenus dangereux ce qui
explique également la véritable psychose
de certains et le calme des
scientifiques français